ladies and gentlemen welcome to the Tim
Dylan show live from Los Angeles
California undisclosed location anyway
everybody happy did you watch the
Academy Awards wasn't that fun
see Joaquin Phoenix go up there and talk
about milk man Hollywood's dead huh it's
just a carcass of an industry
it truly is nobody cares everybody
Pacino De Niro these people don't die
they just keep going I don't know how
they get the best medical care they're
legends they're literally legends now
like you see them you're like is that
them they're literally chupacabra like
when you see them on the red carpet and
then you have Joaquin Phoenix up there
talking about the abuse of animals how
many states do they want Trump to win
forty forty five what would make them
happy Brad Pitt's up there doing
impeachment jokes yeah I gave more time
than they gave Adam Schiff I forget
which guy he mentioned but he's up there
doing it you know impeachment is like no
one paid attention to the impeachment
process by the way it came on the heels
of the other fake thing you did about
Russia that didn't make any [ __ ]
sense that you were unable to prove you
had Robert Muller and everybody's gonna
prove everything we're gonna prove that
you know Putin and Trump are
incommunicado you were able to prove
zero nothing not an inch it was an
embarrassment instead of talking about
health care and jobs you're writing a
spy novel that nobody wants to read okay
you have Chelsea Handler and Kathy
Griffin out there talking about
espionage as if they have a [ __ ] clue
as to anything that goes on Chelsea
Handler is now an expert in espionage
she spent a decade talking about her
snatch and now she's talking about uh
you know counterintelligence I mean guys
shut up enough I'm starting to think
they are Republicans I'm sort of think
all these Hollywood [ __ ] are
Republicans they're like [ __ ] it we're
making a lot of money
these [ __ ] Aikau
look fat and we do not want anybody else
sitting I'm starting to believe that I'm
starting to believe it's a coin tell Pro
operation where they just tell people
they go hey Joaquin Phoenix why don't
you get out there and talk about milk
it's almost like it was a sketch that
was written out by like billionaire
corporate donors they're like you know
it'll really get everybody you just get
out there and no don't talk about
immigration that you could pull some
heartstrings there people might agree
with you talk about animals talk about
factory farming when half the country's
on heroin and there's a opioid epidemic
and people are working three jobs to
drag themselves at a bankruptcy because
they got sick and can't afford the bills
ignore all of that because that could
wit that could get people on our side on
your side and just talk about the abuse
that cows suffer I mean what level of
privilege do you have to be in society
to think that the biggest problem is
[ __ ] milk
I mean how lost do you have to be as a
human being to think that the real issue
here I'm not saying animals are always
treated nicely I'm saying this we eat
animals that's how most people survive
they eat animals they've been doing it
forever okay now some people don't eat
animals they eat vegetables good for
them
some people abstain from animal products
but can we all stop with this insane
crusade to end the consumption of meat
and dairy as if it's the biggest problem
in the country this is a carcass of an
empire this is a scam that stopped being
viable 50 years ago this country by the
way I mean I look at these elections as
like that there's somehow people that
are still in the Enron office building
arguing about what the lunch counter you
know what the deli is gonna serve we're
done folks
and we're talking about milk this
psychopath and these people they look
weirder and weirder this celebrity like
they look odd when you see them on the
red carpet they look you know source
Iran they have a
to them where they they look less and
less like people Timothy sha'lame does
not look like a person he looks like a
feather he floats around he's this
weirdly you know genderless you know
attractive but weirdly youthful like a
guy who's kind of cast in amber that
he's never really gonna age and you know
all of these celebrities are starting to
take on this look which is strange to
people people don't quite understand it
the outfits are odd the way of speaking
is odd that the patterns of speech are
odd they're just not on planet earth
anymore they come to eat it looks like
spaceships are landing and they come in
from their other planets to discuss
things that we should be doing it really
is strange people don't know what to
make of this people in middle America
don't understand people in in on the
ghosts don't understand this stuff
anymore
it's creepy to them there's a level of
grand I remember growing up watching the
Academy Awards watching the Emmys people
being into it people kind of caring
people thinking that there were stakes
and that these things mattered and then
something happened where it just became
like odd these celebrities are much
odder and Andrew Schultz made this point
that if you don't have social media now
and if you're not accessible in any real
way and you just live in some castle you
just live in some big house and
everything you say is is handed to you
from a publicist or a lawyer
you seem odd now like a lot of these
people are they're no longer relatable
in any way to us they're not because
most people have adapted and they're
like I have these tools to communicate
directly with fans and then you have
this really elite sanctum of Hollywood
this really elite group of people they
don't speak ever unless they're at a red
carpet or they're you know it's a very
staged production where they go on Jimmy
Fallon or they go on Seth Meyers and
they sit in the chair and they have five
minutes of banter and it's like well hey
you were in Italy recently and it's
nothing real about it you know you were
in Italy you know I was in Italy when
you weren't Italy you loved let me do
that when somebody will be like remember
remember when we were both in Italy it's
it's so insane that this even still goes
on and the lead-in to these shows is
like you know a mass shooting or you
know a senator who's been found to be
taking a bribe or some scientists at
Harvard who got caught sneaking
biological samples to the Wu Han
province of China which no one really
talks about and then then we we go to
Jimmy Fallon and Seth Meyers who want to
talk to somebody about the time they
were both in Italy it's crazy you got to
look at some old late-night shows where
guys like James Baldwin the famous black
intellectual go out and talk about real
[ __ ] they talk about real stuff but
these late-night shows they're their
viewers are falling they're decreasing
steadily and they're terrified of
upsetting anybody they're terrified of
losing a fat housewife from Galveston
Texas who thinks it's fun that Jimmy
Fallon plays with Muppets every night
and that he sings with the band and he
does dances and he brings out the kid
from stranger things and they play
hopscotch or whatever the [ __ ] they do
I mean it's imaginary lob imagine having
a real job we're like you working in a
factory and a guy next to you is like I
just got diagnosed with cancer I don't
know what to do and you go home and you
put on Jimmy Fallon and he's playing a
game with Zac Efron or he's going to the
Olive Garden with post Malone like it's
the crit so that's where these
celebrities that's the only time that
they ever communicate with peoples on
these like late night shows which are
like a dystopian nightmare reality in
which insanely wealthy people sit there
and have meaningless convert like
meaningless conversations beyond the pit
now if I'm asked to do panel and I have
to say this I do have to I have to be
clear about this if I'm asked to do
panel on one of these shows I will I
don't think I think I'm beyond where I
should be doing stand-up in a 5min
said so so my stand-up doesn't really
work in five minute little bits and I
don't I can't do it if I can't say what
I want to say and you know years ago we
submitted to do stand-up on these late
and I chosen the goats to ranty and it's
too dark and I was like you're right
you're right and I'm good with that
like I I love my friends who do it I
love what Norman does it I love what Sam
Morril doesn't I love what I watch
people do it I don't need to do it I'm
not bitter and angry everything's fine
but if they want to talk to me on panel
I will do that now here's what will also
happen that episode won't air that's
also gonna happen because I'm it's not
gonna air because I will ask them what
they're doing like I will look at one of
them as I'm sitting there go let me ask
you a question what are you doing like
what in God's name are you doing um I
mean I know this pays well but I will
just keep bringing up real [ __ ] and
there will be censor and because you've
got to realize the people that go to
these shows like the people that attend
imagine going to New York City the
greatest city in the world in my opinion
um and n I'm right but imagine an in
London's a goth nightmare the food sock
shut up
Shanghai that'll have its time it's
coming don't worry about it you'll have
the next century let me have the past
one thank you imagine going to New York
City with a group of your friends group
of your friends the great restaurants
the great public spaces all the things
you can do the museum's and having one
of them died really like to watch a
taping of The Tonight Show tonight I
imagine being on a trip with someone
that said that and just the it would be
like you dude they're just feeling in
the pit of your stomach of a doctor
saying positive to you that's what it
would feel like to me of a doctor
telling you that you you had AIDS you
know not even a it's something even
worse than that like just you have six
months to live
we're sorry inoperable the word taping
of The Tonight Show to me is synonymous
with the word inoperable like be hearing
it's inoperable
because if I mean can you imagine
hearing that from somebody like I want
to go to a taping of The Tonight Show
tonight why
why would you ever want to go see a
thing that you can see on TV and you
could watch it on TV and shouldn't but
what in God's name you don't know who
the guests are they're all like who
knows who it's gonna be
it's gonna be exciting we're gonna see
Jimmy's gonna come out maybe I'll have a
field piece or goes to the Olive Garden
with post Malone or cardi B and they can
sit in the Olive Garden where people
have worked 16 hours to make a living
and and they soak their feet every night
because they swell because they're on
them all day and they're taking
amphetamines to just to just keep doing
it and keep [ __ ] answering the
questions that fat tourists from Ohio
have about penne alla vodka they they
have to do that and they're all drugged
up and they can barely have a cigarette
break and when they do they go outside
it's just a cacophony of New York City
blaring horns and ambulances and they go
back and in the Olive Garden and then
they have to hear from their manager
that well you got to look good today
because Jimmy's coming in with post
Malone now I'm sure that there are some
people that enjoy this their work in the
out garden because they're so broken
they've been so destroyed in every
possible way that some of them might get
excited maybe they're young kids but
there's got to be a guy that considers
having a Travis Bickel moment there's
got to be there's got to be a guy that
thinks of throwing a tour of Italy on
the table and then lunging and falen
there's got to be one of those chefs in
the back that's had quite enough of this
[ __ ] what is the bit that the Olive
Garden is good it ain't that's the bit
that rich people do let's go eat this ah
[ __ ] that regular people eat and pretend
it's good let's go to good no it's not
it's not good it's disgusting and
everybody who eats there hates
everything you believe in or say you
believe in Jimmy Fallon you know it's a
repulsive restaurant it is repulsive the
Olive Garden is there's no quality about
it in New York City you could get
anything they serve they're better in a
pizzeria and they go to the Olive Garden
and I guess the joke is like we're
taking cardi B to Red Lobster we'll get
a teacher how to use silverware I don't
know what the joke is that she's like
what's Ritz cocktail and you have to
what is the bid I've lost on the bed I'm
really truly lost on the bit but imagine
someone suggesting so this is why these
celebrities and the people that rise to
that level are so insanely disconnected
because they're only showcased to us on
that show or on a show like the view
where they go out and it's just five
women screaming about politics and then
a celebrity comes on to promote some
movie of the week that they're doing you
know I mean it's it's it's it's truly
crazy I want to hear a podcast from
these people where's Margot Robbie's
podcasts I want to hear Emma Stone's
podcast you know Emma's having panic
attacks she's it's too debilitating
panic attacks that she's suffering I
feel bad for her I don't like anxiety
but maybe you're too rich and you're too
white and you're too pretty and you're
too successful but it doesn't fill the
whole Tim it doesn't fill the whole when
you get all that money and success it
doesn't feel the whole you're actually
more upset good suffer in silence shut
up about it
shut up then I understand that I
understand that it doesn't fill the hole
I'd do things all the time to fill a
hole and they don't I get at but just
enough already we don't need a whole
story about this you have Joaquin
Phoenix talking about animals yeah we
should can you get his speech up this is
the craziest thing it makes you want to
like just be vapid wealthy people that's
what we want we want to worship you we
want you to be pretty we want you to be
you know lucky we want to believe those
things can happen to us we don't want
you we don't want to be moralized you
don't need to come in here and tell us
everything that we're doing wrong but
it's part of the problem part of the
real issue and I think a lot of these
celebrities is they just don't there's
no place for them to be human beings
because all of their their their people
are terrified they might say something
that'll lose them a deal
they can't be the spokesman for that
face cream if they say something
untoward now if I was working on the red
carpet I would turn around
she Ronan and I would go sir see a lot
of people don't know this but you're a
huge fan of Donald Trump you're you're a
massive fan of Donald Trump and you
actually campaigned behind the scenes
for brexit is that not true
soare see you source you're from Ireland
a country where people [ __ ] in the
street don't you think don't you think
even if we're just to protect immigrants
you shouldn't let them in there okay
country with people having 70 IQ Ireland
where my family comes from the goddamn
Irish the damned wit do you have his
speech yeah you want the transcript or
you want the audio read some of the
transcripts okay I'll start at the
beginning god I'm full of so much
gratitude right now and I do not feel
elevated above any of my fellow nominees
or anyone in this room because we share
the same love the love of film lie I'm
it's a lie
I just want a thing I don't feel
elevated how not you won this is this is
the problem people can tell these people
are full of [ __ ] immediately
I don't feel elevated know the people
that aren't elevated or in their seats
you've been elevated you don't it
doesn't matter how you feel
it's again the feeling stuff and this
form of expression has given me the most
extraordinary life I don't know what I'd
be without it but I know I've got a
pretty good idea of what you'd be you'd
be in a bar you know somewhere getting
hammered yeah I have a good idea
Joaquin of where you'd be nothing good
but I think the greatest gift that has
given me oh I think the greatest gift
that it's given me and many of us in
this room is the opportunity to use our
voice for the voiceless right yeah and
and we say who they are and we choose or
the voiceless how great is that
how great is calling large swathes of
the American public voiceless they have
voices they're using them all the time
on things you then you shut them down on
social media they use their voice and
you go you're a Nazi and you take their
account away half the time a voice with
a voiceless
who are these voiceless people all I'm
inundated with all days people's voices
Facebook Twitter Instagram everybody
nobody shuts the [ __ ] up there's nobody
in this country without a voice unless
they literally don't have a voice unless
they literally had their throat removed
with cancer there's nobody that doesn't
have a voice in fact I think people's
voices are a little too loud the
voiceless that [ __ ] might have worked 10
years ago there's no one who's voiceless
anymore Bill Cosby's tweeting from a
prison cell at Snoop Dogg who is void
and I mean look and I know that he's
using it as like you know an expression
to mean people that don't have the
political power and economic power that
he does but words mean things and when
you start saying that people are
voiceless and that you need to speak for
these voiceless people again you've set
up this entire thing that's wrong it's
completely wrong you guy I I am here to
which speak of those who appointed you
to speak for the voiceless because you
won a trophy because you pretended to be
the Joker why you've got why isn't it a
scientist who speaks for the voiceless
or a doctor or a philosopher why in
god's name is it you who who made you
the the [ __ ] standard bearer keep
going I've been thinking a lot about
some of the distressing issues that we
are facing collectively oh good that's
when you're watching you're like oh good
I think at times we feel or were made to
use how but here's how good he was a
joker this is how good of an actor he is
I know that's not true
I know that you're not spending a ton of
time thinking about these issues because
you did a phenomenal job in that [ __ ]
movie and you can you know Serena
Williams in viña you just can't spend a
like Serena Williams is not sitting
around thinking about trade it's not
happening I'm telling you right now
Venus Williams whichever ones still
relevant [ __ ] off I don't care no it's
the other one shut up they're both fine
the point is this I'll be both of them I
was at a my grandfather used to I used
to play tennis in mutton town Long
Island perhaps you've heard of it
he had a tennis court on his property
okay and I would play tennis too okay in
a in a classy way
I think at times we feel what were made
to feel that we champion different
causes but for me I see commonality I
think whether we're talking about gender
inequality or racism or queer rights or
indigenous rights or animal rights we're
talking about the fight against
injustice we're talking about the fight
against the belief that one nation one
people one race one gender or one
species one direction dominate control
and use and exploit another with
impunity
I think we've become very disconnected
from the natural world and many of us
was guilty oh hey Joaquin guess who's
guess who's suspect number one who's
been a little disconnected from the
natural world now who's gonna talk by
the way this flows in this is what I
love they disconnected from the natural
world will now flow into how no one's
supposed to eat animals what have you
ever seen have you watched any nature
documentary ever any show ever on nature
nobody in the natural world is handing
each other trophies there's no bear
getting up at a podium and going I am a
voice for the voiceless I am here to
give a voice for the pit like what are
you even saying
the beginning of that is all like you
know
Bard College which is the Columbia
School for Women and I'm not saying that
it's because they're women but Bard
College freshman year paper that was
handed to him before he got on stage
continued we go as many great women that
are very smart in this country by the
way I'm gonna name five Barbara Bush
because she knew her husband was
involved in the JFK assassination she
helped cover it up I will tell you why
that's great it's great dig she's a very
smart woman Tana [ __ ] Mogo
she's an Instagram influencer from Las
Vegas who married Jay Paul and a fake
wedding and I'm a fan of her I don't
know why but I stand her I don't know
why I like her she's got the big tits to
fake face to fake lips but there's
something about her I like is something
I like people to come out of Vegas it
just seems like everyone born in Vegas
should die so what someone makes it out
of Vegas I like it I liked it she's
telling us lip gloss and big tits
that's what we get so I like her so
Barbara Bush Tana
um I don't know anyone else now and I
can't I can't do the whole episode I
can't I can't it's gonna take me 40
minutes a time you're gonna say Michelle
Carter at some point no because Michelle
Carter just got lucky
yeah she just got lucky she was a
devious [ __ ] who told her boyfriend to
get back into that car and after that
documentary I was over him but I was I
was over her but I was over him I'm over
him it's another good-looking guy who's
like I wanna die and then she's like die
die I'm over him I'm over his family I'm
over HBO giving documentaries to this
horseshit when what some white kid gets
killed shut the [ __ ] up I mean enough
already is black people getting shot in
a CVS give them a documentary who cares
I'm sick of this [ __ ] it's a small town
it's a everything on Netflix Nate feels
about a small town that's being eaten
alive by something well let it get eaten
that enough sick of this [ __ ] Michelle
Carter where's my [ __ ] special
you got specials on HBO where the
trailers like I don't do stand-up I just
like driving around in a car yeah go on
what we're guilty of is an egocentric
worldview the belief that were this
center of the universe we go into the
natural world and we plunder it for its
resources we feel entitled to
artificially inseminate a cow and when
she gives birth we still her baby how
are the people how are the people in the
developing world going to eat Joaquin
without some fusion of science and
agriculture how are people in the third
world going to eat dummy they can post
mates vegan avocado toast to their house
like you probably do and some terrified
open mic comedian has to go past your
gate and and hand you something okay
Bernie Sanders should execute all of
these people and I will support him
everyone knows that I'm a Tom Steyer guy
stance tire steyr is starters is the
candidate to win and I only say that
because I don't know who he is
and I won't know I won't know whose tire
is until I write his name in on the
ballot in 2020 but if Bernie said here's
what we're gonna do we're gonna reign in
Wall Street we're gonna take all the
CEOs out and shoot him in the face and
then we're gonna go to Hollywood another
shoot them in the face and then we're
gonna give Tim Dylan a show on HBO and
not some con to convince a boyfriend to
kill himself because Tim Dylan's
actually talented stop giving murderers
all the airtime can we stop giving
murderers all the airtime in this
country now you got to murder someone in
a small town to get a show now I'm sorry
I didn't kill someone in a small
American town you know enemy Steven
Avery's had nine seasons of a show
because he's he raped and murdered
people in a town you know in a salvage
yard so he gets his show but I can't get
a show because I haven't done that I
haven't slit someone's throat with a
carburetor in Wisconsin I apologize
because everyone wants to sit around and
watch murder all day in a small town
where people go oh you know I'm so down
an earthy and let's just shook up the
whole town continue I apologize and when
she gives birth we still her baby even
though her cries of anguish are
unmistakable then we take her milk these
people are all for late term abortion
they're awful late term abortion they're
like we stole the cows baby you you
don't mind if women take their baby and
throw it out of the window at
cedars-sinai because it gets in the way
of the book that they're writing again
no consistency here I would love I would
love if he got up on stage grab the
trophy went I loved death thank you and
just walked off stage I would clap and I
go [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] yeah consistency I
stand sire sire Stan then we take her
milk that's intense are you in that's
Tom stars logo are you in it's like a
bunch of seventh graders about to
vandalize their gym having a powwow are
you in it's literally the stupidest logo
I've ever had but he's for structural
reform which is it real and doesn't it's
just a coupling of words I've always
found hilarious structural reform oh so
we're gonna it will also reform the
structure of it good
keep going I apologize then we take her
milk that's intended for her calf and we
put it in our coffee and our cereal and
I think we fear the idea of personal
change because we think that we have to
sacrifice something to give something up
but human beings at our best
are so inventive and creative and
ingenious and I think that when we use
love and compassion as our guiding
principles we can create develop and
implement systems of change that are
beneficial to all sentient beings and
the environment now I have been I have
been a scoundrel in my life I've been
selfish I've been cruel at times hard to
work with and I'm grateful that's so now
now that's all over that I'm a
millionaire
my selfish ways are done now that I have
all the money in the world now that I've
done amassing money with the selfishness
I've decided to be a great person
Chelsea Handler buys a house in Bel Air
calling that that tiny Mexican guy in a
show a nugget for five years and then
decides that you know she's Malcolm X
when she has a house in Bel Air
it's nobody on the journey decides
nobody has these revelations when
they're broke by the way he's not
interesting nobody has any of these
revelations and so they have a lot of
money yeah there's something about
sitting in a pool every day and watching
Netflix documentaries about murder that
makes you feel pretty damn lucky these
people go I'm pretty lucky I don't live
in Ferguson Missouri I'm pretty lucky
and then they they start telling
everybody what to do and then they start
criticizing like you know oh you know we
steal the baby from the cow we steal her
baby it's it's the most insane we don't
want to give up milk in our cereal I've
been a scoundrel I'm grateful that so
many of you in this room have given me a
second chance and I think that's when
we're at our best when we support each
other and give me a that's when we're at
our best we support me
we give me another chance because I've
been horrible and abusive to people on
SATs and I'm a dick but I also am a
genius he's an amazing actor so when I
treat people like [ __ ] because I'm
talented would find there's some
trade-off there I you know I'm very
happy we're our best when we forget
about the scoundrel that I've been
for my entire life and career we're at
our best that's when we're all at our
best when we support each other not when
we cancel each other out for past
mistakes but when we help each other -
right dad you know what that means hey
don't dig too deep bond Oh Joaquin don't
dig too deep on Joaquin I'm saying no
more milk I'm I'm on the thing I've been
here that bullet points by a freshman at
Columbia University to read here at the
Oscars don't go looking back for the
many moments where I was a scoundrel
let's not none of the cancelling let's
start the process of giving me more work
and money because that's when word our
best but when we help each other to grow
when we educate each other when we guide
each other toward redemption that is the
best of humanity when he was 17 my
brother wrote this lyric he said run to
the rescue with love and peace will
follow man did the wrong brother bite it
did the wrong brother check out huh I'd
love to have river back he'd probably be
saying the same [ __ ] but I don't know at
least more poetically I'm so I mean just
enough already with these people
it's really it's it's it's it's
incredulous like you watch it and it's
it's not even funny anymore because
they're so disconnect like there was a
period of time and it was funny when
like Sean Penn would bring up like a
Native American to accept the award from
and they would start yelling about
something it was kind of funny because
you're like yeah these people were
[ __ ] alright I mean I don't know
what's gonna happen now but this is at
least something now these people are
just you know and so he landed it with
his brothers later how sweet how sweet
we got a we gotta wrap and then we'll be
back alright everybody we are back now
we had to interrupt the show I had to do
three stand-up comedy spots - at The
Improv and one at the Comedy Store and
then we had to go to Mel's drive-in and
get to wellness shots and a waffle
sundae I had a little bit of my cayenne
pepper and ginger wellness shot it was
not
good so I opted to not be well then took
his down
he likes spice it's Texas boy I don't
know what the [ __ ] that was but it was
not for me
that well in the shot I was very angry
earlier about the Oscars and I I'm right
about everything I'm saying but you know
we're calmer now we've all had our food
everybody is we understand that you know
people deal with all kinds of things
there are people that are not trusting
the process with my new business venture
which kind of is upsetting me many
people know that I'm a comedian that's
we've kind of established that already
but what people don't know is that's not
my real my real passion my real passion
has always been jewelry and I've seen
the look on someone's face when you give
them something that is special and
unique and to me what that is is a
perfectly set stone perfectly set stone
it could be topaz could be one of the
other ones and jewelry has been in my
past now a lot of people are like
they're not did we have a mail-order
jewelry business called Jules bye
podcaster Tim Dylan a lot of people have
given us a lot of money under now
getting angry at us because the jewels
haven't showed up at their home for them
to sell now this is the type of amateur
[ __ ] that I expect from some of
these people this is an amateur hour
okay number one you you don't need the
physical jewels to sell you can get out
there and you're selling a lifestyle
you're selling an idea you're selling an
identity so you're gonna get the jewels
they're coming but I fear for many of
you because the complaints are so
unnecessary and I just feel like a lot
of you aren't taking it seriously you
have one job when you sell jewels my
podcaster Tim Dylan - you have to
convince people that they are not happy
because they don't have the right
jewelry and you also have to convince
them that they need to sell jewelry for
me and you
and this whole calm trying to start a
company here and a lot of people don't
take me seriously I'm trying to start a
goddamn company in operation I just feel
like a lot of you are ungrateful because
many of you have no idea how to be an
entrepreneur and I am a businessman
that's what I've been since I'm a little
baby boy I've been a business boy for
ever in my whole life all of my
existence has been business crunching
numbers chopping the onions making it
work fit in a square peg you know around
whatever the point is I don't need your
[ __ ] ungrateful mouth all the kid is
in here the drool kits not here
improvise you stupid [ __ ]
figure it out it's gonna get there it's
on its [ __ ] way
you're gonna get it all so we're coming
up with the sales strategy because I
realize that many of you need much more
help than I had anticipated which is
okay
I want to give you that help but many of
you are not sales people you're not
closer so I can hear it in your voices I
can hear it in your emails that are very
and that are rage-filled when you send
me an email and you're like I spent all
this money I didn't I haven't been given
any guidance or any how but I don't even
have the jewels where are the jewels I'm
telling everyone I'm selling jewelry for
you I can't even do it you know all I
hear is failure and I don't know is that
who you are is that who you want to be
that's not who I want to be that's not
what I am so we're doing a seminar in
and then Arizona Hilton or Marriott
we're gonna see and it's gonna be three
days I just give me a three day
intensive sales training seminar we're
gonna train you on the product you got
to get trained on the product then you
got to get trained on the strategy and
then once you have the product and the
strategy you good to [ __ ] go okay
product plus strategy sales strategy
okay now I'm gonna show you this is an
example and again you're not gonna be
I'm at for a very long time maybe never
but if you listen to me I've invited Ben
to lunch Bennis someone I have not seen
in a very long time I've invited him to
lunch by messaging him on Facebook we do
a lot of our ads on Facebook stay away
from Twitter stay away from Instagram
stay away from god forbid tick tock
stay on Facebook what I like about
Facebook is that Zuckerberg they're not
crate they're not trying to verify
everything on there they're just letting
it fly which i think is very important
for a small business that she's starting
so i'm message ben and i want to get
lunch with him and i don't bring up
tools up by podcaster tip Dylan in the
message I just reconnect with him
authentically and he agrees to have
lunch with me at the local diner now
we've done some of our bullshitting and
now it's the time when I'm going to
pounce
the word is pounce like a puma would
like a big cat if you ever seen a big
cat [ __ ] something up with his paw
that's what we're doing but we're
helping people do you understand that
I'm helping him but because he is so
lost I need to to paw him like a large
cat would to help him now see this is
the time when I'm going to do it ha this
lunch has been very good I've enjoyed it
it was great yeah it's very so good it's
very good I enjoyed I like rye bread me
too
it's it's wonderful so nice to see you I
haven't seen you since high school
how's things it's pretty good you know I
think could be better though not gonna
lie well let me tell you story do you
want to hear a story you have time for a
story I'd love to hear one I have
nothing to do when I was a young child I
became obsessed with jewelry I would
steal it I would wear it and I would
sell it and even though looking back on
that now that seems immoral mm-hmm
what it did was give me a real
understanding of the market the market
for jewels
I have an opportunity for you I have a
company right now that I haven't told
anybody about because I'm still trying
to decide who's worthy about knowing
about it
it's called joules by podcaster Tim
Dylan now I see your face and you're
surprised in you're shocked and I think
maybe feel a little lucky do you feel
you feel a little lucky you're not wrong
to be lucky what I want you to do is I
want you to go into your community I
want you to go to your family your
friends people who trust you people who
you built rapport with over your entire
life and sell them jewelry that I have
provided for you to sell them I get my
jewelry from the best jeweler I won't
tell you where okay but have you seen
the movie uncut gems yeah him there's
nothing like the look on someone's face
when you when you marry them to a
perfectly set stone many people aren't
happy in their life they're fat and
they're on heroin and the reason that
this is the case is because god is dead
and the country is [ __ ] now even though
it's kind of good it's still [ __ ] but
one thing that always glitters brightly
is a jewel and everybody wants it
that's why do you do you remember she's
no white in the Seven Dwarfs yeah what
were the dwarfs doing they were mining
for little jewels that is the oldest
story in America Snow White in the Seven
Dwarfs really yes so in the beginning
there were jewels there will always be
jewels and when you you have to make
people understand how lucky they are to
be in the unique position of being sold
jewelry
over the phone or in person at their
house because you say you could take a
trip mrs. Miller when I go into a sale I
go
hello mrs. Miller you could go anywhere
and buy jewelry but you're not buying it
from a trusted name and you're not
buying it from somebody that has a
passion so what are you really doing
you're being stupid and if you're stupid
you're going to fail but I don't fail I
win because I'm not stupid I'm smart my
jewels are bright they shine remember
the rap song shine like the diamond
shine bright like a diamond shine bright
like a diamond that's not the way it
goes but I like the way I'm doing a
little better shine bright like a
diamond the best thing about these
jewels is I'm not only selling them to
you I'm selling them to you so that you
can sell them to other people you're
trying to help me I want to help you I
want to help you create a revenue stream
I don't want you to have to get up to
work a nine-to-five job like some dumb
Pig I want you to be able to create your
own business and your own opportunities
I want you to have multiple revenue
streams I want you to have a sales
strategy that works for you I want you
to put your tentacles into the community
and then choke people very softly so
that they understand that jewels my
podcaster Tim Dylan is the [ __ ] thing
that is gonna be the thing that's gonna
happen another thing I want to touch on
is that Aaron Hernandez doc was so
stupid and people in this country are so
incredibly stupid that when everyone was
like it's mind blowing you have to watch
it it's so mind-blowing the people in
the documentary are so dumb Aaron
Hernandez of course is the guy's a
closeted gay guy who kills the guy or
whatever you know it and everybody was
like in the documentary they're like how
could he do it how could he kill someone
and he
in place of football it's like you hey
idiot athletes kill people we know this
none of it's fascinating
we know this they kill people they beat
people they beat their wives I can't
believe he's sad at all in front of them
I can't believe we do this yeah rich
people kill people all the time how is
this shocking when you hear that that's
mind-blowing and then you watch his
documentary you realize how [ __ ] we
are as a country we don't learn any
lessons here
we're like goldfish in this country we
have no memory we cannot retain any
piece of information we start at zero
every [ __ ] day here I can't believe
you watch that documentary all these
people like it doesn't make any sense
he's successful and rich and you just
killed somebody how does it happen and
then he goes and plays football like it
didn't happen
yeah yeah that's what people do I don't
understand what's shocking about it it's
just so sad what what election I mean
there's 20,000 arenas 20,000 seat arena
is being filled up so people can watch
puppet shows what election folks is
gonna help here I mean I'm trying to I
mean I don't understand there's 20,000
people to file in an arena to see two
puppets argue with each other I'm not
throwing you know whatever you could
fill in who the comic is they're they're
making a lot of money a lot more than me
but when you see 20,000 people laughing
hysterically at a puppet what what do
you think it's gonna be look like here
what country do you think we're living
in are you aware of where we are and
who's in little houses and in the cars I
mean they want it look at puppets they
want to listen to puppets argue with
each other
puppet shows
or what I liked when I was three when I
was three years old I thought puppet
shows were fun because there was a
little thing at my school was a puppet
theater and the little puppet came up
out of the little theater and they had a
fun show I got over that by three and a
half I was done with it I said I don't
like puppet shows anymore because I
bought puppets your parents will get
your puppets this is what happens this
is the natural reaction if you're not if
your mind has not been completely like
shattered you get the puppy you buy the
puppets you play with the puppets for a
few hours you go this kind of sucks I
get it it's a puppet and then you're
done and then you move on but there are
large swathes of the population millions
and millions of people who still enjoy a
puppet him so I mean I'm gonna try to
say I want to be better than people I
don't wanna be that guy but at a certain
point when everybody's like your
politics if all these people are doing
that debate we're gonna structurally
reform the what they're watching puppet
shows how this country doesn't have a
dictator already is it amazing I'm
amazed that we don't have a dictator
already with what people wear where
people are mentally in this country
people are mentally broken in this
country their minds are broken it
they've been polluted with sugar and fat
and drugs and booze and cheap
entertainment and they like puppet shows
you would talk to him about climate
change have the puppet do it I mean
I mean have a puppet moderate to debate
it folks I don't know what you think is
gonna happen
good listen Bernie Trump good whatever
Bernie's got great points I'm a big fan
of people having health insurance I
really am I know some people are you
upset at me about that I also on the
other flipside don't know if he'll be
able to get it done I know where we're
living
you know I know in order to get anything
done in this country he's got to go into
the woods and convince him to a bunch of
people in hoods in the middle of the
forest it's a good idea you know you've
got to convince a bunch of people
barbecuing human beings you know that
it's a good idea that we keep
pre-existing conditions in and I know
that can be challenging but I also am
deeply skeptical of the ability for
change because I'm I've met people and
I've spoken to the people and I just
don't know you know what yeah you know I
mean I remember I was I was in rehab
with a kid and I've talked about this
before we got out of rehab and he
invited me to his girlfriend's house or
his house that girlfriend was there and
he wanted to watch you Jeff thought I'm
special now I I think Jeff is talented
I've never met Jeff you know all the
disclaimers said whatever you know who
cares and [ __ ] Jeff down I'm like
well I'm gonna go on the road with Jeff
not him I'm gonna open up I dress up
like a big puppet talk about Disney
kidnapping your kids I don't think
that's gonna fly but I'll give all the
disclaimers you know Jeff's great he's
got a lot of money's talented whatever
God love him God God you know hey
boo-boo-boo
they wanted me to watch it Jeff thought
I'm special and they said our favorite
puppet is peanut and I said what so I
didn't really know I knew Jeff is
ventriloquist but III didn't know like I
don't know people got that invested in
the puppet I thought it was maybe like
dirty puppet [ __ ] like dark puppet you
could have fun with puppets right I
guess I don't know
but what I went to this house and I
watched it with them and I watched how
excited they were getting in there go
and when Jeff brought a peanut they went
nuts they sort of clapping on the couch
I said you I looked at this kid knowing
you should do heroin like you should go
back to doing drugs that was probably a
better life for you than sitting here
and having your mind numbed and they
just laughed so hard at this puppet and
I realized that for most people life
like for most people a lot of human
beings out there I don't know how many
people let's just say far too many okay
for far too many people life is a bowel
movement you know it's just like the
AIDS they don't have they just are
existing on earth and they don't think
too much about anything going on around
them they don't have the mental faculty
to comprehend what is going on they do
not understand what is happening and
then the people that do have those
mental faculties and do understand
what's happening tend to poison everyone
else and the reason for that is because
they meet them like the butchers the
Clintons they meet all the people and
shake their hands they do all these
events in the go yeah they're watching
puppet shows so why not kill people
poison people
star wars you know these people are
watching peanut I mean so I mean I'm not
trying to say we don't have a lot of
bright people here but the average
American like the average American and
this is why I could never run for
anything that in my past and present
future
but the reason that could never run for
anything is because I go to average
American is the problem like the average
American who wants to watch the puppet
show and and just and just like they
just I mean you look at the people that
are on a cruise ship and they just want
to eat and just float they just want to
eat and fart and float that's what a
cruise is it's a bunch of disgusting
people that want to just [ __ ] on a boat
and watch garbage comedians garbage
music garbage entertainment stuff their
faces with food pulling this important
go by a knick-knack go home and put it
on your refrigerator okay and then go
watch a puppet show I mean give him free
college they're not gonna go they won't
go we need to force him to go would have
gone to their head you can put in
military you gonna try them in trucks
give him free give him everything
cancel the student debt cancel it
do what you want I you know peep they
don't want enough people just talk they
don't care they don't they don't even
know why there no one knows why they're
on earth so like the idea that most
people are gonna try to waste any time
figuring out anything they just go hmm
they shrug I just want to feel things
their minds are dislocated from their
bodies they're impressed by light shows
you go to Vegas you sit down a
restaurant they got light shows
everybody yeah
yeah I would done a restaurant in Vegas
there was a frog singing and it's like
it is something fun about it because
you're in Vegas but like this is what
people want they want the puppets
that's why politics is a puppet show
they're all puppets people are war or
politicians puppets is it cuz you like
actual puppets do you like actual
puppets so why wouldn't the politicians
be puppets I mean fast cars we like to
see cars drive fast the gophers you're
called go first like to see people beat
the [ __ ] out of each other you know
that's it it's what it is you just you
want to see porn where people are beaten
within an inch of their life strangled
choked defecated on you can't common
less Bloods being drawn you don't I mean
this is what people are doing out there
they're eating cinnamon roll pancakes at
Denny's or 1,900 calories I get it
they're eating salted caramel banana
cream pancakes that doesn't even sound
good
serve with a pitcher we've been renting
on the patron episode serve with a
pitcher of caramel pitcher not a side a
picture of it you could drown your
pancakes and caramel and then go see the
puppets you know people tell you proudly
in America readings not for them there
no readings not from me proudly long
islands famous fat well round is the
only place people take a an intense
pride in their ignorance it might not be
the only place but it's one of them they
just laugh in your face it go huh I
don't know anything about that
you start saying something intelligent
they'll laugh at you
I don't know anything about that big
smile on their face because they think
they've won and they have they've won
they're there they've won cuz they don't
know and then one day you know it all
delights just go black anyway it just
all goes black the end produced by Dick
Wolf it's all over
thank you know so it's not that I'm like
politically I think Sanders is really
interesting I thought trouble is gonna
be interesting I think Trump's somewhat
less interesting than I think I think
the response to Trump is interesting
because these [ __ ] Psychopaths on the
other side cannot effectively counter
him at all and it just proves that
they're as wantedly the Democratic
parties just wanted ly corrupt as
anything and they're trying to steal it
from Bernie and they're trying to give
it to boo to judge because he works for
the CIA or whether he knows it or not
and he probably does it's just what it
is okay and watching this in real time
watching the biggest human trafficking
case with huge political implications
watching that completely go away and get
out of the news cycle is [ __ ]
fascinating watching this guy get killed
watching that all be covered up watching
them try to steal the election from
Bernie in [ __ ] real time I don't care
if you like Bernie or not what's
happening right now is [ __ ] historic
you're watching the ruling class of this
country losing power and trying is
scratching desperately any way they can
to rest and put power back in the
control of the billionaire cartels of
Wall Street Hollywood big tack big
pharma all of these [ __ ] things these
elite you know organs of opinion whether
it's the Washington Post or MSNBC or the
New York Times they're all trying to
diminish Bernie's accomplishments they
did it with Trump they've been doing it
you know soon as Trump got elected there
was a coordinated attack on him from
every which way not to say some of it
wasn't justified he's a shady guy but it
was over the top
these things are kind of invented this
collusion rush and narrative never
played out and the amount of the amount
that it was hyped do you said that the
president was an agent of a foreign
power for two years and then turned
around with oops I guess we were wrong
it's absurd and they're doing the same
thing to Bernie in the primaries you
have to realize that doing the exact
same thing they're throwing everything
they can at him whether you [ __ ]
think his economic policies are
reasonable or not understand the moment
historically that you're living in many
of you do not grasp it yet because
things are so good they're still waffle
sundaes and puppet shows
I don't know that that'll be around
forever and I know that when there's
still waffle sundaes and puppet shows I
like the former many of you like the
latter but because they're still waffle
sundaes and puppet shows nobody has
fully taken time to appreciate the time
and place in history you are in now we
are seeing the cracks of a civilization
become too big to hide and the fractures
are becoming too deep and too meaningful
to ignore and it's the national security
state it's big money players and the
people in this country are turning on
the government they are turning on the
established order
they have been fed a diet of [ __ ]
and lies for very long [ __ ] time
we've seen horrible abuses of women
children human rights abuses all of the
[ __ ] coming to head in the last 24 to 48
months and people are flipping the [ __ ]
out people's minds have melted the
queuing on cult is people that really
can't handle how much real [ __ ] is
[ __ ] up so they've kind of invented
this subterranean war that Trump is
having with these deep state people and
he's gonna you know bring justice to all
of these people and whatever all these
people that they think are involved and
you know and there's no real proof for
that there's no evidence for that other
than conjecture and and
it's not to say that there aren't slimy
shady people in Hollywood in Washington
and we I talked about that as much as
anyone on this [ __ ] planet I mean
maybe not as much as anyone on the
planet cuz I want to have a little fun
and laugh a little bit - I just can't
[ __ ] talk about that every bucket
minute but you know we get how [ __ ] it
is and I get the you know people wanting
there to be this war happening I've
never I've never not wanted it to happen
I hope it is happening I just haven't
seen any evidence of it and if I don't
see any evidence of something then I
turn into Rachel Maddow sputtering on
about Russian BOTS and Putin like a
lunatic and I refuse to let my mind be
melted even though it's a mind melting
time it's a mind melting time Trump is
the president you know that's wild in
and of itself Alex Jones is one guy in
Austin Texas that had a news you know
organization one guy that became so
threatening rightly or wrongly whatever
you want to say and all the tech
companies kind of got together in deep
platform to him and took all of his but
you know he was kind of unperson -
whatever you want to say disappeared and
it's crazy time that you have one person
with that reach that becomes that much
of a threat to whoever that they got a
you know take quick action to get rid of
them and you might agree you might go
hey he's [ __ ] up things at Sandy Hook
blah blah blah none of this is we're not
immoral arguments about all these things
one of what I'm telling you is just sit
back and think about how inconceivable
any of this was even ten years ago that
these types of things were happening
because again this is the result of the
the independence of media it's starting
to become a real problem for people in
power it's becoming a real devastating
trend for them and
I have to do everything they can and
they're starting with apps and the apps
not working well the app doesn't work
the app doesn't tabulate the votes and
then they report that Pete named he came
in second and third and they barely
mentioned the Bernie won and then
they'll tar him and feather them and say
this about him and not about them and
they'll you know arrange it so or
hopefully they won't but they're gonna
try as hard as they can to get their boy
in the white house their gal whoever you
know the same reason Trump you know
dropped that big bomb and Syria soon as
he got antes playing the game it's just
what it is the mother of all bombs the
Moab
you know we're defeating Isis you know
if you still believe that I got eyes I
don't know what to tell you I got some
jewels to sell yeah I mean why is all
these things that don't exist that we
pretend we make them op or which or we
trot them out when we need them Isis
yeah yeah there are us Islamic state
there's horrible they're terrorists
they're bad bad boys and girls over
there we gotta go set him straight
we got to set him straight and then we
go do that and then you know six months
later they're back again because I guess
he the most powerful fighting force in
the world because I thought we were but
somehow they evaded us or they went
underground and it came back up and it's
like you know what what a fun little
whack Amole situation we've got going on
there in the Middle East and it'll truly
never end and Bernie's really not gonna
do much about it either because he's
been he's talked about the
military-industrial complex and I
respect that but it's just how do you
unwind that you just don't folks you
don't really unwind that and you people
out there to think he can unwind it
understand that you can unwind it but
it's it's not gonna be good it's gonna
be bad it's not and I'm not saying don't
do it because it's morally and
imperative that we don't do but
understand the amount of money that
these people are making they're gonna
fight back it's gonna be a fight and
listen you might win you won't but
understand it's gonna be bad they're
gonna do bad things I'm not saying it's
not a worthwhile endeavor but understand
what's happening a lot of you have this
pie-in-the-sky
view of things that you things were just
gonna change peacefully and playfully
and everyone all right now is your turn
it's not gonna happen dude if these
people are not going to give up power
without a tremendous fight they're not
gonna give up the money they're not
gonna give up control and you're not
taking it from them it's not gonna be
violence in the street it's not gonna be
had to fight it's not gonna be your
black backpack in your hat and you're
throwing an egg it's Gavin McGinnis none
of that matters to these people they
don't give a [ __ ] because they have the
police and the military and all the
technology and all the money and all the
resources and all the land and all the
corporations and all the tack and the
bubala what you have is Twitter you have
Twitter you got nine online you mean
when now if we have some massive
demonstrations a massive civil
disobedience if we have a guy like
Bernie Sanders maybe he's a
transformational figure maybe he's not I
don't know I'm skeptical about how
anybody but understand what this [ __ ] is
what it is at its core who we are
stop forgetting who we are ray I was on
the phone ray today brought up a great
point who didn't people think we are out
there you know we gotta get back to wit
what hot get back this country is a scam
it ran out of steam about 50 years ago
it's been propped up by cheap credit and
Foreign Wars and it's gonna fall and
it's gonna be bad
not immediately and not you know but
it's coming it's coming
and those fat behemoths know down deep
it's coming that's why they all file
into the arena and watch the puppets
because maybe they're smarter than us
maybe they're actually the smart ones
maybe they just want the raw [ __ ]
form of what this really is why dress it
up with Pete Budaj hedge and Amy
Klondike bar whatever her name is
why dress any of this [ __ ] up why not
just go back to it in its original form
furry puppets because that's what it is
entertainment
bread and circus spectacle so maybe I'm
the idiot that tries to make sense of it
and they're the people that just file in
and watch the puppets you know because
those puppets are probably a hell of a
lot funnier than people to judge maybe
they're not as always they leave this
broadcast with great hope for mankind
[Laughter]
we've got a bright future ahead in this
country and don't let anybody tell you
we don't don't let anybody tell you we
don't believe in yourselves and others
invest in your communities invest in
yourselves push yourselves to the limit
you are who you've been waiting for
Greta Thornburg is gonna lead us all
it's all fine it's all great the waters
gonna not run swell up and everybody's
gonna be fine by that little house by
the coast doesn't matter it's all good
go on the date with that woman with
[ __ ] you know a [ __ ] is that
kleptomaniac who's has a vicodin
addiction don't worry about it nobody's
perfect just bite it off bite off more
that you can chew and toke it down it's
America goddamn it get your cinnamon
roll pancakes and go watch the puppets
it doesn't matter you're lucky to be
here you're lucky to be here at the end
and if you don't think it's the end it
might not be the end but you're lucky to
be here in the previews for the end
because we're previewing the end the
previews are we're watching the previews
we haven't started to watch the movie
yet that happens when the dollars no
longer there is world's reserve currency
that happens when the pandemics break
out in the plagues when coronavirus
comes here you know because that's all
that is it's just you know Harvard
scientist you know China's doing bio
warfare and something slips out in the
Wuhan province and blob
you know it is what it is they're
cooking up your death in a lab somewhere
they're cooking up your death in a lab
and you're watching the puppets and
they'll put little masks on the puppets
to make it fun when we're all in [ __ ]
hospital beds they'll put a little
corona mask on the puppets for all of
you and you'll like it you'll enjoy it
you'll love it because you're a big
[ __ ] an oxygen air and water has been
wasted on you but that's no reason not
to have original wallet none at all
you need a wallet need a wallet Ridge
wallet is a front-facing wallet if that
means it goes in your front pocket okay
idiots goes in your front pocket it's
made out of what is it steel Bend carbon
gives it's made out of some [ __ ] it you
ain't gonna it ain't gonna go away it's
around forever unlike us rich wallets
good because you put a credit card a
debit card a little cash nothing major
you're forced to streamline your life
it's a great wallet I haven't been at
six of them they're just good they make
you focus on what's important in your
life
Riggs our promo code is Tim T I am if
you're gonna buy the wallet and you
should for your family and friends
because they're gonna need a wallet when
they have coronavirus in their [ __ ]
about to die the ridge wallet is
beautiful I'm a fan of Ridge baby I love
a ridge you know have you ever been in a
beautiful natural setting and you just
see ridges the little ridges the little
mountains the ridge wallet has nothing
to do with that but it is a wallet that
you can use it's not leather it's modern
it's hip it's sleek it's a tick-tock
wallet you're gonna be you're gonna be
19 again your [ __ ] is gonna be hard
you're gonna have a big future area
you're gonna be famous and rich and
everybody's going to
yeah your parents gonna lookie it with
pride your little brothers gonna stop
doing heroin in his room and come out
and tell you that that wallet inspired
him they're gonna say you're the one N
Dennis you're the one Peter you're the
one that helped me turn it all around I
saw that Ridge wallet I said I want to
be like my big bro who's got a Ridge
wallet you put that ridge wallet in your
pocket and you go on about your day you
know this [ __ ] dog that walks around
upstairs I want to kill these people
you mean you know musicians are the scum
of the earth I mean let's really be
honest about what musicians are they the
absolute scum of the earth
truly they are scum I mean have you ever
met a musician that didn't deserve to be
burned alive these people did dogs and
their kids walk around upstairs all day
and all you hear is this [ __ ] things
in the house it goes all over the floor
I mean I'm just sick I'm amuse you shut
the [ __ ] up
Ridge wallet is a fun wallet it's fun
and hip and young it's not old like a
boomer it's young like a Zoomer you're
gonna be just tick tocking waving your
[ __ ] around tik-tok saying hey look at
me and all the ladies are gonna love you
all the ladies are gonna love you
they're gonna come in they're gonna say
hey
you come make a memory with me buddy
I'm gonna take you to Vegas and you're
gonna win big oh you're gonna win big
you fat slob you can have all the money
you want they're gonna fill your face
with meatballs and put their [ __ ]
right in your mouth and you're gonna be
so happy you're gonna go back to your
house and it's gonna be bigger and
shinier and newer and all the neighbors
gonna be happy to see you they're gonna
go how are you Clark
they're not gonna void your gaze like
they usually do and get into that cause
with their kids talk about you as a
cautionary tale a creepy guy who they
wish didn't live on this block they're
gonna say that's Clark our buddy our pal
he's uh he said what do you call that of
the communities a pillar of the
community he has a ridge wallet son you
want to be like that man he's got a
ridge that's what's gonna happen if you
buy the ridge wall with promo code Tim
if you don't use promo code Tim your
entire family will die blue chew Oh
promo code Tim Ridge is that fine yeah
tell me what to say just say get 10% off
today hey get 10% off today today right
now as soon as you hear this Ridge Ridge
calm slash Tim T I am rude calm /mt I am
in all seriousness it's great way to
support the show by the [ __ ] wallet
use the promo code blue true [ __ ] don't
work what else is new get a [ __ ] blue
true you're gonna get a big [ __ ] in the
mail now let me read this guys remember
the days you always ready to go now you
can increase your performance you get
that extra confidence in bed listen out
blue true calm that's blue like the
color blue in case your full [ __ ] we
know many of you are you could take them
any time day and night even on a full
stomach and since they're chewable they
work up to twice as fast as a pills you
can be ready whenever an opportunity
arises just make sure that the word
consent is in your mind if you could
benefit from more confidence where it
counts blue true is the fast
you know I want to go up to his stairs
and choke the dog to death in front of
him he's not moving now cuz he kind of
knows when I'm upset at him but all he
does is like scamper up and down the
fire you know it just it's in consider
you know apartment living is truly in LA
it's for the Damned in New York is fine
but in LA you should own a [ __ ] house
thanks for telling your friends about to
show you [ __ ] nothings they're made
in the USA who cares the [ __ ] pills are
made in the USA it's the only thing
we're making in the USA it's even worse
than made in the USA wish do I made
somewhere else they made in the USA his
Blue Chair Oh true blue chunk since blue
cheese prepares and ships direct at
cheaper than a pharmacy and best of all
there's no more awkwardness right now
we've got a special deal for our
listeners blue true comp listen promo
code Tim you just pay five dollars
shipping promo code tan blue to calm
promo code Tim five dollars shipping
that's blue2 calm promo code Tim try it
free you've got nothing to lose many of
you you dicks not great probably but if
it's hard it's better so get this it's
free you people you know what are you
gonna do I would die I've been given a
samples of these I should I'll try them
you know I don't want my dick to be hard
for that long I don't want anybody
getting the idea that it's about Sam I
just wanted to be hard enough for it to
just do what it has to do I don't need
it to be hard forever
you know but many of you have got
something out there to prove I don't
really care I'm not in it for anyone
else you know what I mean I feel I'm
like a king sexual object should be
brought to me and then we I should just
they then they're taken and killed you
know what I mean I don't care if it's a
person that's about to go to the gallows
it's like well the King the King didn't
seem that into me today he didn't really
go for that many rounds hey shut up
you're about to get hung he [ __ ] him
and he just throws him away all right
folks it's all a joke love is so
important blue true is the better
cheaper faster choice we thank them for
sponsoring the podcast Valentine's Day
is coming up you wanna [ __ ]
valentine's day you wanna [ __ ] her in a
mouth don't you want don't you want to
[ __ ] her in her mouth for Valentine's
Day you just [ __ ] are you [ __ ] right
in the mouth you know cuz this
Valentine's Day st. Valentine whatever
that is that true no probably not
it's Valentine's Day folks [ __ ] her in
her mouth in her ass [ __ ] him in his ass
in his mouth whatever you want to do as
long as everybody's above age nobody's
being coerced nobody has a gun to their
head you know even if it's a prostitute
you don't want to let them down
don't let your prostitute down with you
a beauty of [ __ ] little soft penis
then she's got a he to talk about the
fact that you were in a band
God God musician should just be attacked
every day in the street people that play
music for a living should be attacked
every day in the street every day they
should have not a moment of peace that's
blue chunk sorry blue chill I'm so tired
blue cheese Blue's Clues blue balls
that's blue2 calm promo code Tim try it
free it is your dick not work and your
girl's a [ __ ] who we gonna call blue to
calm coz if you got a self dick she's
gonna go [ __ ] her father and that's not
good blue cheese calm she's gonna [ __ ]
dad she [ __ ] her dad all right um well
sunken city banks sponsor this show so I
can make a little money here please
sitting here at [ __ ] two o'clock in
the morning screaming like a lunatic I'm
looking at my roommates costumes in the
corner in a room here I'm gonna start
putting them on blue true calm promo
code Tim tried free get a ridge wallet
got some cocktails get the other thing
we the the manscape thing
you know we're gonna trying to get more
ads here but you know the people that
get us ads seem to be they seem to be
very relaxed about the ads they all seem
to be like oh yeah there's no killers
out there I mean I'm sure there are
killers in the podcast ad space we don't
know any of them these are all fans of
comedy which means they're derelicts
they're degenerates you're a fan of
comedy you're degenerate most of the
time not all of the time not fans of me
fans of comedy you know like the thing
like to be fans and specific people is
fine
but to say you're a fan of comedy means
you should be hit by a car okay I do
yeah you fan of comp what does that even
mean I'm a fan of calm a fan of laughing
we're all a fan of laughing shut up
stupid not you everyone so what I mean
is that if you want to advertise on the
show please just contact us okay
email [ __ ] the show do we have an
email for the show the Tim Dylan show at
gmail.com a loss and not with horseshit
if you have a real ad now I don't care
what it is
we have no moral qualms about anything
here I'll advertise for a dictator
literally I will advertise if the u.s.
is gonna invade your country and your
genocide will dictator email me and I'll
try to build up some good good good
karma for you on this side of the pond
I'll try to get some some good thoughts
out there in people's heads about what
you're doing email me bin Salman no but
he's our best friend
we love Saudi Arabia because that's who
we did 9/11 with have you been at
Chile's recently Chile's yum-yum-yum
even you want your ribs come and get you
ribs I want my baby that bit I mean it's
a real that's the country ribs come to
Chili's come to Chili's and then go
watch a movie
go watch a movie in a big parking lot
after you filled yourself with chilies
maybe Joaquin Phoenix will be in it oh
boy it's late we're getting little nutty
folks this isn't me it's the the waffle
sundae talking we shouldn't have had I
should have had the Wellness House that
wellness shot sitting it's decent
it's not bad shut up you [ __ ] trying to
make me feel bad I didn't have mine I
took one sip of that I'm like the [ __ ]
I'm it's a wellness shot at Mel's Diner
scene same wellness ah we don't have
much else to say here folks I read we
don't guarantee results Jules my podcast
for Tim Dylan full website being
launched we have a real coming out of
real people talking about how this has
literally changed our life how literally
before they started selling jewelry they
were living in the street and they were
living they were bathing in their own
piss but then they started selling
jewels they started pissing on others
that's what America's about one day of
bathing in your own piss the other the
next day you're pissing on someone else
because that's what this country is
about piss and puppets we'll go see the
Pope ooh yeah 9/11 fake nobody works in
those buildings they weren't even there
I'm kidding I'm joking I'm joshing yeah
I'm pulling your chain we're just
pulling your chain but it was Vic ah
probably I don't know what are you gonna
do by the stick pill please that's all
we're doing here selling your [ __ ] pills
I just ramble in between cocktail ads
just put your mushy mashed potato
cocking
in somebody but before you do chill
choose some of these blue choose you
animal goodnight